and on Thursday I think I've done very
well I've held off to this point in the
show before mentioning guys seminal work
as Mike Young in neighbours when when
will he mention my work now obviously
this is never far for my my neighbors
some good haircuts in there yeah but
that's the who's who I think I know
where did neighbors can I have that of
course you can
hey that is yours that is true cuz that
Livia Europe you were a big neighbors
fan well still are I'm sure in the early
90s but we know what's its neighbors
have sort of come back into your life it
never goes away well it has sort of come
back into my life because there was a
little we had a little sort of Twitter
exchange recently because Annie Jones
who plays Jane has gone back on the show
Plain Jane superbrain find Jane timid
brain mile the love of my life of course
and there was a storyline where that was
implied that she was gonna sort of go
off with Stefan who plays all roles on
Robertson and I just sent this tweet out
going Jane know and then Steph made this
video saying well you know nice tweet
guy you know why don't you come back on
the show and why don't we have it out
together anyway so is it sort of funny
banter and then we found out that
actually those guys were here in the UK
so we caught up and you know we we took
some photos together with any sort of
you know that's fighting in any sort of
keeping us apart oh there you are
they were playing Jay into a brain very
upset yeah
it's gray-haired man will I go with
[Applause]
[Music]
you